contentious g7 summit President Trump
clashing with the media while also
trying to hammer out agreements with
world leaders Trump mixing it up with
members of the press and also defending
his trade policies earlier today I
actually have a question for you on next
year's g7 summit but can I just clarify
something you said you mentioned earlier
today one question let me do the
clarification and then I get to the
question oh no you talked about why I
keep repeating what some people would
see as the clear lie well it was NX
during president I know you like
President Obama but it was an X during
President Obama's day the back-and-forth
and the changing statements from
yourself so that I'm sorry it's the way
I negotiate this has to be a deal that's
been there for us and if it's not better
let's not do business together back here
at home Democrats being criticized for
attacking Trump on the economy while he
was in France what the president is
doing is totally irrational and it is
destabilizing the entire world economy
Donald Trump has no plan this is just
chaos and trade war by tweet is harmful
to the US economy the way this president
has been using tariffs he's been using
them like a meat cleaver or maybe the
better word is a tweet cleaver the
current strategy I'm not even sure you
can call it a strategy I think the
president has botched this thing yeah
all of this comes as the president was
forced to defend himself from a report
claiming he suggested using nuclear
bombs to top hurricanes from hitting the
US Trump says the story is ridiculous we
think this is a really important topic
well I I think it people agree if they
love the idea of nuking a hurricane okay
it's not surprising okay none of this
story is surprising or alarming at all
because Trump is always an inquisitive
out-of-the-box thinker he's always every
five seconds he's asking a what-if type
of question and the media turns it into
a front page story and then he's like I
didn't mean it I didn't mean it some
well above up but it's just a question
and it's sometimes these
counterintuitive ideas work people
dynamite oil fires right I did some
research people fight fire with fire
right they're called back fires Dana you
know this also it never rains on Russian
parade
why is that cloud seeding right they
induced the rain before the parade so
these ideas these crazy ideas had to
come from somebody with big ideas like
let's bomb that hurricane what I think
is alarming is that somebody wrote this
down in a meeting in a National Security
Council meeting and gave it to the media
yeah that makes them feel important like
they were trying to embarrass the
president he's not yeah and he should he
should be proud of that idea sometimes
this show knocks me out so the two of
you are saying that you believe that he
did sing I do I do I do I would without
now the president says it's fake news
and that he never said I think it's fake
news that it's a serious consideration
he never said right I can imagine that
he would have asked a question in a
National Security Council meeting sure I
think for example when I remember in was
at 7:08 there was like our asteroid
heading towards Earth like what are we
gonna do what are the options what could
we do exactly knock it out with a
hurricane
I think the bomb causes the hurricane to
go towards the asteroid protect the
nuclear weapon break into pieces and
destroy the rest of Isis never thought I
would Google how do you knew this guy to
get to the g7 to which was fascinating
to watch this guy's the American Bowl in
the Euro we need china shop right and he
just he walks in there and says I've got
big ideas I'm putting America first
you're all globalist I don't care what
you have and if you look at the leaders
of Canada not Boris Johnson but formerly
the UK France Germany Italy many of them
are fundamentally unserious people about
the real problems we're facing in the
world today they just go there I want to
talk about climate change I get that
they brought Zarif there this is the
foreign minister of Iran and he
basically the McCrone has them at a
table they say that the president knows
about it but they're all like yuck the
photograph that the French released is
the reef at the table and they're all
laughing
about a link this guy is with a
government that terrorizes innocent
people Nicole beer yes I love that you
pointed to me to make sure that I knew
who we're talking about but the truth
isn't I agree that I think it really
disrupted the whole purpose of this
entire meeting do I think it's a good
thing to open the discussion 'he's there
and that makan is trying to facilitate
this conversation
sure but president Trump got her out of
the Iran nuclear deal because he didn't
believe it was a good deal he is yet to
put forth what he thinks would be a
better nuclear which I would like to see
that however you know I don't think he's
really in a rush to have these
conversations he has said that he's he's
open to it but he's not in a rush she
really wants Iran to feel that squeeze a
little bit more in my opinion but I do
think communication is good I don't
think this weekend was a good time for
them to really focus on that first day
with regard to nuking a hurricane you
blow that there would be damage to human
beings from the fallout from a nuclear
explosion you understand I am willing to
listen to all sides of this debate
because this is how you view classic and
the second not true this is a this was a
bad weekend for the president terms of
dealing with the number one issue the
number one issue is we've got a trade
war going on China that's negatively
impacting the global economy tweek any
Japanese no he didn't he didn't get our
allies to say we'll join you mr.
president and put pressure on the
Chinese instead he get what he does is
he skips a meeting on climate change
right --chrome did say that he that the
French at least the French position was
to agree on the intellectual property
but they didn't in other words Dana if
you get a deal if you was if he was able
to exert more pressure by bringing our
allies a table but he didn't do it I
don't think that's gonna get announced
at the Gees well he did I think he
didn't do that I don't think he dealt
with the situation in terms of the
Iranians or the Syrians Assad which
continues you talk about Isis
Isis is growing by our own cosmos the
leaders of the g7 are unserious they do
I'm just glad you said that the China
showdown was the most significant issue
were facing and not climate change which
is like so most people aren't even
playing at his level
yes it's willing to do talk it's to
Pete's point whenever you you know
you're in episode of the Trump show it's
no matter how many number there are
variables they are the size of the
variables it's always Trump versus X Y &
Z whether it's hurricanes or Denmark or
the media but no matter the size of the
variables it's always one to one it's
him everyone else outside comment about
a tent and people are running with it
he's not saying to let him back in and
have it I just see it again that's him
saying I'm open to things because he
doesn't like black and white answers why
would you let Russia